das einzige was mir spontan einfällt ist
richard yates zeiten des aufruhrs wer
trinkt ununterbrochen da wäre ich gerne
dabei ich weiß nicht wieso das jetzt ein
typisches thema sein so jay gatsby die
party ist oben ja da wäre ich auch gern
dabei gewesen einfach nicht als
hauptperson weil die scheitern ja alle
und gehen elendig zugrunde sondern ist
rogers am ende genau da wurde einfach
echt noch gefeiert und getrunken aber in
bombastischen stil frauen tragen kleider
perlenohrringe wie ich kettchen 50er
jahre die ehre als zigaretten noch als
nahrungsmittel galten bei richard yates
ins die fünfziger und da war es auch nur
ja ja das war einfach weiter damals war
auch alkoholismus bestandteil der show
geschäft ja ich bin jeden tag morgens
macht jägermeister
das ist heute so unerfreulich das ist
alles so wahnsinn vegetarier veganer
trockener die fotos von grills moody's
auf instagram posten in den 50ern war es
schon das bewusstsein nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg dass man das leben noch mal
anders genießen darf also ich glaube die
dem ging es dann auch in manchen phasen
echt richtig dreckig die ganzen frauen
waren alle psychisch krank tausende
colours die ganzen amerikanischen frauen
weil die das hat auch was mit repression
zu tun und nicht nicht unbedingt mit der
einnahme von das glaube ich an die
nation aus gesellschaftlichem und
individuellem fans werden wir nach
exzessen gefragt und kommen gleich
wieder auf problematische konstellation
zu sprechen
ich möchte gerne in einer zeit dabei
gewesen sein wo es wenigstens schon
telefone gab
ich finde telefone das ganze andere zeug
nervt er so voicemail und solche sachen
aber telefone und autos nicht schön dich
auch schon auf das finde ich auch schön
ende